Hello
Oh, hello.
My name is Adam Smith, I'm calling from Nobelprize.org,
the official website of the Nobel Prize.
Do you know what time it is right now?
Yes, it is just coming up to twenty to two
in the afternoon.
OK, twenty to two good.
If I ramble on can you cut me off at ten to
two ‘cause I have to give a talk at two,
and set up my slides.
Of course.
You know, I have a keynote at a conference
here I'm giving at two.
Yeah.
Quite right, well I can bet you'll get a stunning
reception.
How nice that you're sticking to schedule.
Well, first of all, you're in Germany now
so how did the news reach you?
Just the committee themselves, they called
me around 11:30.
And what was your first reaction?
Well, I mean, shock, a little bit of quakes
for about 20 seconds, then equal measures
of happiness and fear.
What's the fear about?
The fear is, you know, your life being changed.
You know, I mean I really like my life the
way it is now.
And I don't need… you know…
I'm busy enough as it is.
So I don't like saying no to people and I'm
going to have to learn how to say no more.
And I mean obviously I'm happy with it but
I am a little bit scared about how much it
will, particularly over the next three months,
affect things.
Yes indeed.
It comes with the territory, right?
You yourself have tended to tread a fairly
unconventional path.
I mean you resigned from Bell Labs, you stepped
away from academia.
Quite a risky strategy.
Well, yes and no.
I mean, in my opinion the only real asset
one has is one's reputation, right?
I mean any company, and institution can go
belly up at any time.
But if you have a good reputation, you know,
you can usually find somebody who can, who
thinks they can use what you have to offer.
So, I never really viewed it as all that risky
at some level.
Frankly, I guess, I don't really understand
why people, why so many people, are so risk
averse.
You know there's always ways to wiggle your
way out of any situation if you're motivated
enough.
This is a chemistry prize, do you consider
yourself a chemist, a physicist, what?
Ha!
I already said to my son, you know, chemistry,
I know no chemistry.
Chemistry was always my weakest subject in
high school and college.
I mean, you know, it's ironic in a way because,
you know, trained as a physicist, when I was
a young man I would look down on chemists.
And then as I started to get into super-resolution
and, which is really all about the probes,
I came to realise that it was my karma because
instead I was on my knees begging the chemists
to come up with better probes for me all the
time.
So, it's just poetic justice but I'm happy
to get it wherever it is.
But I would be embarrassed to call myself
a chemist.
Last question.
You've changed fields a few times in the past.
Do you think you'll change field again?
Well, I was almost certain I would before
this prize happened.
Now it's going to be, now people are going
to want to keep me from changing too much.
But, you know, it's probably a quixotic dream
but, you know, I've always been… when I
was a kid I wanted to be an astronaut and
I've been watching with jealousy the development
of the private space transportation companies.
You know, if I could ever get away from this,
it might be fun some day.
Hell, if I was just sweeping the floor of
the assembly bay while they were putting the
rockets together I just think that would be
a blast.
You know?
I don't know, I'm an engineer at heart so
that impresses me – like super-resolution
it's just a fascinating engineering challenge.
It's been a great pleasure to speak to you.
Thank you very much indeed.
Congratulations again.
Alright, good, thanks a lot.
Bye, bye.
Thank you, bye bye.